we want to continue our discussion about
this whole mental health idea we don't
need to deal with guns we just need to
deal with mental health well then it
would follow that we need to actually
make mental health treatment more
accessible
last week we looked at republican texas
congressman tony gonzalez and i played
clips for you of tony gonzalez saying
this is just a mental illness problem
these shootings it's not about guns it's
just about mental illness that's all
that we really have to deal with and
then we looked at tony gonzalez's voting
record when it came to increased access
to health care and it was atrocious
voting against obamacare expansions
voting against all sorts of different
funding for health related programs
because it's just something they want to
say
it's not actually something they want to
deal with well now we have an example of
a republican texas governor greg abbott
at a press conference last week greg
abbott again said the issue here it's
not about guns
it's about mental health here is greg
abbott explaining this
so the
the ability of an 18 year old to
buy a long gun
has been in place in the state of texas
for more than 60 years
and
think about during the time over the
course of that 60 years
we have not had episodes like this now
texas actually has a pretty big mass
shooting problem
but one of the things that has changed
even if they want to make the case well
the access to guns hasn't necessarily
changed in the last 60 years
the marketing to people
to get more and more guns has changed
over 60 years but importantly the
culture around guns has changed over 60
years where because of this corrosive
american gun culture
and the educational problems and
the almost
uh
the delusional nature of the american
right
more and more people come to see
firearms as a way to solve problems
that's a cultural issue so things have
changed but now we're getting to the key
part
and why why is it that for the majority
of those 60 years
we did not have
school shootings
and why is it that we do now
the reality is i don't know the answer
to that question
however
what i do know in in talking to the
leaders here
as well as leaders in other locations
around the state
and that is one thing that has
substantially changed
is the status of mental health in our
communities
what i do know is this
and that is we as a state we as a
society
need to do a better job with mental
health
anybody
who shoots somebody else
has a mental health challenge
period
we have we as a government
need to find a way
to
target that mental health challenge
right
now
the issue with all of this is as usual
there's massive hypocrisy
uh greg abbott cut
211 million dollars from a mental health
commission there's a report on ksat
which says
abbott has doubled down on his stance
that mass shootings are an issue of
mental health and not gun access however
in april abbott slashed nearly
211 million dollars from the health and
human services commission which oversees
mental health services in texas
abbott diverted the funds to add to his
effort
to send national guard to the texas
mexico border
known as operation lone star
no other texas agency received a more
significant cut
than the hhsc when abbott slashed
funding
texas ranks 44th in the united states
for an overall ranking of mental health
measures
and last out of all 50 states in access
to mental health care
the republican right
never pays a political price for their
hypocrisy and that has to change
but think about the absurdity of this
the problem isn't guns it's mental
health
well okay i mean to a degree
we've been talking about the problems
there for a long time although there's a
cultural problem as well we got to
figure out how to deal with mental
health oh well how would we do that i
don't know i cut funding
to expand mental health care in my state
which is already dead last on access to
mental health care to instead use the
money to send national guard to the
texas mexico border
that's you know and of course unless
their constituents are able to follow
and understand and be aware of this
there's not going to be any
accountability there simply isn't it's
it you
it's not a crazy thing to think a voter
could understand okay let's see
maybe guns are part of it maybe they
aren't but if mental health care is a
part of it then what is greg abbott
doing to deal with that actually he's
making the problem worse by defunding it
to send national guard to the border oh
i should vote against him i should vote
for betta o'rourke
i should you know would it stay home
but i shouldn't go and vote for greg
abbott if that's the case but they don't
hold themselves to the standards which
they
appear to try
to hold the left to
and at this point conservatism
fundamentally is about there are in
groups
and there are out groups and it doesn't
matter what aspect of our politics we're
talking about we must protect the
in-groups at all costs at the expense of
the out-groups even if we are openly
hypocritical openly hypocritical well uh
it when when it comes to immigration
well we must protect the in-group which
is the natural-born american citizens or
whatever when it comes to
uh religion the in-group is christians
when it comes to you you understand the
idea here and whatever principle they
state
is going to be ignored
when it would no longer protect whatever
the in group is at the time
and mental health now is the issue
in order to protect the gun owners and
not have to do anything about the guns
but we're not actually going to deal
with the mental health issue when we
have opportunities to fund it we take
money away don't you dare use my tax
money to help solve that problem we're
pro-life right
but don't you dare use my tax money
to improve foster care
or to help single mothers
or to fund comprehensive sex education
which reduces the demand for abortions
no no no no no
uh this is a sickness
i mean listen even look at police right
oh police are always right and we must
support them always when there's some
police use of force against often it's a
non-white person but then all of a
sudden well look at what happened look
at how the police were treated on
january 6. no no no now the police are
bad and the justice system is bad
because the in-group the trumpists are
sitting in pre-trial detention it's
there are no actual principles that go
beyond
supporting the in-group and we are very
much seeing that here